for my sister she was shot dead in cold
blood
in the middle of street we need the
truth we need the truth of the law say I
think the truth would be justice from
itself we have so many victims so many
people who are still hurting today
F in any circumstance any of that has a
connection was myself in relation to
people level and allegations or whatever
then I would think that that's difficult
for me he was working
the new Northern Ireland can be
deceptive it looks like it has left the
past behind but actually that legacy of
the troubles is always present and no
one knows how to deal with it what do
you do with hundreds upon hundreds of
unsolved murder cases pursue
prosecutions forget prosecutions and
just pursue the truth there's a danger
that victims could end up with neither
if the politicians can't find a solution
under soon they believed and injured
could lose their best hope of truth or
justice an old home movie and memories
they are all an Traverse has left her
older sister Mary was shot dead and
their father a Resident Magistrate
wounded by the IRA I didn't have my
sister never I got married you know to
share things with to ask advice about it
speak to think about my children you
know that's all taken away and when she
was murdered it left a huge void in all
of our lives she was shot dead in cold
blood in the middle of a street she was
completely innocent she was 23 years of
age walking home from mass you would not
in a normal society and stop looking for
a murder and that is what's happened
with her 15 people died in the Loyalists
bombing of McGurk's bar in Belfast
kitty Irvine was one of them four and a
half decades later her son Sam vividly
recalls the explosion and I could see
the smoke like my bedroom window I could
see the smoke eventually took my fingers
right in my ears and just at that midori
about and I got here me on saying oh no
not Kat ain't not Kelly and I went down
the Stars and I guess he mcgraw me
sitting on the city looking at the the
imitation fire used to go around with
the saloons and I could see the tear and
I won't shut irony just took my her
relatives have long alleged that the
state colluded with the loyalists who
bombed McGurk's bar for them the
security forces of questions to answer
to
not just the paramilitaries with the
legacy of violence casting a shadow over
peace Northern Ireland's politicians
agreed a four-point plan a new
historical investigations team a truth
recovery process a mental trauma service
and an oral history archive of victims
stories but none of it is up and running
because the British government has
concerns about national security
Shin thean doesn't buy the claim that
the release of some state files would
pose a threat what we need to see is
first of all the agreement school life
because that would be the test there for
both the British government and for a
Republicans as to whether or not they're
willing to cooperate to satisfy the
needs of victims are you Martin McGinnis
at a point where you're ready to tell
the truth about what you did and what
you know well you see the the the
mechanisms and structures that we ever
need be established make provision for
families who have a grievance as he are
requiring a resolution to the grievance
to go forward to these tribunals f in
any circumstance any of that has a
connection was myself in relation to
people level and allegations or whatever
then I will deal with that that's not a
difficult differently whatsoever John
Kelly a police reservist survived an IRA
shooting his daughter survived the
bombing of her school bus she's First
Minister now and keeping the door open
to prosecutions
certainly from my part there is very
much a willingness to find a solution
but it must be a solution that doesn't
rewrite the power
that does hold out the prospect of
justice for victims as it can be even
pursued at this late stage because of
course we know that some victims have
been beneficiaries of new technology
through DNA and things like that so it's
important that justice still remains out
there for people but it's also important
that we deal with this issue so that we
can build for the future three and a
half thousand people died in the
troubles
three thousand murders have never been
completely solved the Police Service of
Northern Ireland holds nine million
documents related to them in his first
interview since taking charge of justice
and legacy issues assistant Chief
Constable Mark Hamilton conceded that
police need more resources to tackle the
mountain of historical cases the Police
Service of Northern Ireland has six
thousand seven hundred officers you
could argue you could put every one of
them toward resolving the issues of the
troubles but we weren't created to do
that the PSNI was created as a result of
the peace process to police a new
arrangement
therefore there aren't the resources in
play today to investigate all these
crimes concurrently and therefore we
have to play some kind of mechanism to
decide what we can do in the time skills
that we have Antony McIntyre served 18
years in prison for murder
the former IRA member is a critic of
Sinn féin he says it's time to draw a
line under troubles prosecutions I don't
think that the past should be protected
from investigation I think it should be
shielded from prosecution because
prosecution Dre's truth underground
people are going to be much less candid
and although that's a difficult one for
the the victims too to have to swallow
but I feel that the victims are left
with a terrible choice sure that they
choose
justice through retribution or justice
through revelation there were hundreds
of bombings and shootings leaving tens
of thousands believed or suffering but
there is no monolithic group of victims
their views on truth and justice differ
greatly
the poppy Day bombing in Enniskillen
claimed 12 lives relatives say any
process that recovers truth but lets
perpetrators escape prosecution would
send a dangerous signal to other
terrorists you should never give up on
justice even if and yes there's all
sorts of things about you know that as
time goes on things get more difficult
but you don't there's a difference
between accepting that things may not be
possible and actively making them
impossible I think a very important part
of it has to be a common understanding
and acceptance that the terrorism was
not justified and was totally immoral
I'm not understandable and whatever
those phrases that people use and not
acceptable and there's not some sort of
different extinct that makes Northern
Ireland exceptional that means that
murders okay it wasn't 14 people were
shot dead when British soldiers opened
fire during a civil rights march in
Londonderry a public inquiry exonerated
the Bloody Sunday victims their families
got the truth what happened on Bloody
Sunday was both unjustified and
unjustifiable it was wrong for me it
made a huge difference as someone who
wasn't actually in Derry on the day of
Bloody Sunday it was a huge difference
to learn the facts and and and know what
what transpired but for lots of Derry
people they were there they knew Martin
McGuinness has admitted that he was the
eye or Ray's second-in-command on Bloody
Sunday but the terror group has a code
of silence
so do former members envisage him
revealing more no I don't but I do see
an awful lot of older people who will
tell you the
exact truth about money kisses not
because of Martin McGinnis but in spite
of Martin's and our the police service
and other security agencies prepared to
talk about the past it's really
important that the police service in
particular doesn't hide away from
embarrassing facts or from uncomfortable
truths and my chief constables very
clear but normally going to equally it's
really important that we don't have that
information that we put lives at risk
things are very different in Belfast no
but some Irvine still needs to know why
his mother had to die and hopes a truth
recovery process can provide the answer
and we need the truth
we need the treats above all more than
more than I would say I think the truth
would be justice in itself but with the
truth that there will be near an inhuman
anima and people will know who the
perpetrators were and if they come from
the higher echelons of government people
won't know who they are but on traverse
says an amnesty would be immoral that
victims like her sister deserve justice
and anyone with information about the
past needs to help her family find
closure we have got very senior and
politicians with very senior Republicans
who are an I am lawless right the world
as being peacemakers we have senior
government ministers who are lured
around the world has been fantastic for
help with the Good Friday Agreement and
if any one of them knows anything about
any murder or knew anything before a
murder happened or before an instance
happened for a bombing happened then
they need to come for they need to be
held to account there is nobody who is
above the law there won't be truth
recovery unless participants are granted
total confidentiality but there won't be
convictions either unless prosecutors
are granted access to all available
information one process could compromise
the other those grappling with that
fundamental tension are under pressure
to find a balance this awesome before
the plan unravels they are in effect
attempting to write the final
turn up the peace process to help those
left behind find healing myself and my
family pay regular visits a degree of
York and we always come away with
something missing
it's a chef that's one that disappeared
only it's the truth of this disappeared
and if we knew the truth
I would come away feeling awesome I
don't care if some government minister
or some whoever is embarrassed that's I
just want to be able to say to be able
to close my eyes and be able to say to
my sister
there you are Mary you know rest in
peace